foreign
[Music]
ow let go you need to learn some manners
Brandon you know what happens to bad
boys that don't mind Their Manners they
grow up to be bad men
are you listening to me Brandon
Megan
what's up
[Music]
foreign
this is the part where you run
okay you lost your parents welcome home
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
you have to handle this I don't even
take care of my own plants
I have this project at work do you want
to see yes
ever since I was little I dreamed of
this perfect toy that would protect a
kid from ever feeling lonely or sad
Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional is that
a doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for short I can't believe you made this
I love it
great job it's nice
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetables they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes the experts I can
turn off
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk
Make Her Say Something stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
she pushed Brandon onto the road I won't
let anything harm you
okay turn off recalibrating response
model
[Music]
what's wrong with you don't worry Katie
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]